und inspiration of the week kommt dieses
mal von einem model das mit seinem
ehrlichen look polarisiert mobile und
social media star sophia penteli erlangt
online bekanntheit für ihre buschigen
augenbrauen
denn statt sie wie üblich künstlich in
form zu bringen zeigt sich sophia
selbstbewusst und ganz natürlich mit
mono brahms während solche
außergewöhnlichen lux in der fashionwelt
momentan gefragt sind und models wie
mini hallo die laufstege erobern wird
sofias look im internet von nutzern
häufig kritisiert diese wünschen sich
nämlich dass sie ihre augenbrauen der
gängigen schönheitswahn passt so viel
lässt sich davon allerdings nicht
irritieren und steht zu ihrer frau
[Musik]